[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank a job or
as I prefer to think of it dear Joan and
Hank it's a comedy podcast where me and
my brother John we talk about death we
answer your questions give you dubious
advice and bring you all the week's news
from both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John
how you doing well I'm doing I'm doing
all right I just learned that Merle
Haggard died Hank as as we're recording
this I just found out on Twitter about
the death of the great country music
legend Merle Haggard Merle Haggard who
performed one of my all-time favorite
country songs mama tried whether you
know it or not Hank you've heard that
song do you know when yeah it was at
your wedding it was at my wedding it was
my my lap but my first dance with my
mother after my wedding was mama tried
in fact Hank if you don't mind if I
could just jump right into the poem for
today it's just the just the chorus of
mama tried which is a two minute long
song and this is it's it's brilliant
chorus I turned 21 in prison doing life
without parole
no one could steer me right but mama
tried mama tried mama tried to raise me
better but her pleading I denied that
leaves only me to blame because mama
tried mama tried the great Merle Haggard
song just a beautiful beautiful song and
a wonderful song to dance with your
mother to at your wedding
that's wonderful John ear did you have
another poem scheduled that you had to
pump I did I did I had a nice Emily
Dickinson poem but you know what there's
world enough and time to quote a
different poet it's true it's true we're
gonna keep making these you know I think
we've we're going to hit in and not too
long our full year of podcasting which
kind of amazes me I I don't feel like
it's been that long and I think that
would be a great time to retire to
announce our unexpected retirement from
podding well you've ruined it if it's
gonna be unexpected because we're ten
days early but great point but I I don't
think we're going to do that I really
like doing this I really like that we
have
people listening to us be idiots and
thank you all for for for listening and
it's such a wonderful part of my week
cuz I get to talk to my brother for a
full hour and we probably otherwise
wouldn't be having these fun
conversations no it's true and I I also
really love it this is one of my the
highlights of my week talking to you
hearing from listeners and it's such a
supportive listening community a lot of
times on the Internet these days it
feels like you know things are just so I
don't know there's a lot of times
frankly like my life on the internet
isn't as fun and carefree as it used to
be partly because you know just the MOT
my public profile has changed a lot in
the last few years and this place
remains a place that's very fun and
supportive and where we can experiment
and make mistakes and we have lovely
people to point out our mistakes without
being cruel about it yeah for example
all of the people who pointed out that
in our last podcast we discussed parsley
as if it was flavorless pori
parsley has a lot of defenders yes Hank
we were totally wrong about parsley
being flavorless yeah maiya culpa
parsley fans I apologize for insulting
what is your favorite set of leaves yeah
in fact we didn't just get parsley wrong
Hank we've got a bunch of things wrong
oh yeah are we gonna start off the
podcast with Corrections yeah we're just
gonna if I could just make one more
correction before we get to some some
listener questions somebody pointed out
that I said that Boris Johnson is like
the Donald Trump of England in fact this
is only true insofar as they physically
resemble each other
Boris Johnson is nothing like Donald
Trump you know and I want to be very
clear about that
lest defenders of Boris Johnson and
there are many think that they are also
defenders of Donald Trump or indeed
defenders of Donald Trump think that
they also have to defend Boris Johnson
who at least pays lip service to the
idea of a National Health Service yes
right I know nothing about Boris Johnson
and so I have nothing to add my main
feeling about board
Johnson is that I wish that he would say
yes to the AFC Wimbledon stadium I
actually have no second thought about
his work my only problem with it with
him is that this one local zoning issue
and thus I'm going to compare him to
Donald Trump it's not a local zoning
issue Hank it is an issue of of great
import to the future of our civilization
because I would argue that this whole
time what we've been doing is trying to
create a world in which AFC Wimbledon
can go home like the whole time I mean
from 250,000 years ago from the first
humans that happened building structures
that the first tools what they were
thinking is someday one someday we will
be able to build a new plow Lane we have
a question is from Lydia who asks dear
Hank and John please help for the past
week a particularly fierce bird has been
dive-bombing my window and ramming into
the glass with its beak how do I stop
this persistent fiend from attacking my
house how should i reinforce my window
to prevent potential bird invasion you
know Hank and my limited experience with
this phenomenon it's generally a kind of
one-time thing which is that the bird
hits the window and then the bird falls
dead to the ground no no no no this is a
different thing that's when that's when
a bird thinks that it's that there is
nothing there and it's trying to fly
through the window what is happening in
Lydia's case is that your window is
slightly reflective or very reflective
depending on how new your house is and
and and the bird is seeing in that
window a potential rival and and is
defending its territory and is very
upset and stressed out by the fact that
this bird is not responding to its
defense of its territory and it will
continue to attack your window until the
season in which in which this
territoriality is over and that might be
just the breeding season of the spring
it might be through the nesting season
it depends on the species of bird but if
you are having a serious problem with
this the bird is not gonna be able to
break your window but if the bird is
injuring itself which they will do or if
it's keeping you up at night
you can hang like just some some tarp or
like painters tarp that you can get at
the hardware store over your window
temporarily so that it doesn't no longer
is is afraid of itself just what's
happening I've had this happen to me
before several times Robbins in
particular do this it's funny I'm
laughing I'm laughing like birds are so
stupid but of course like I am also
afraid of myself alright egg we've got
another question this one comes from Liz
who writes Dear John and Hank my best
friend is getting married in October and
we were talking about what she'll do if
she's in her wedding dress and needs to
poop with his wedding dresses are tricky
to deal with I have a vested interest in
this matter since I'm her maid of honor
and we'll probably have to help her with
her dress if she does need to poop so my
question is is there a healthy ish way
to just not poop for a day Liz John and
I we are both experts on their style you
have come to the right place this is one
of the very few times when Hank and I
can provide genuinely non dubious advice
I did I'll say before we get to our
level our areas of expertise I asked
Katherine about this because I have
never worn a wedding shirt and I was
like how much of a problem with the she
and Katherine had some very specific
answers she said if if you're wearing
Spanx that you should be concerned only
if you're wearing the kind that might go
up around your shoulders because there's
like full-body Spanx do you want to be
careful if you're wearing full body
specs because that like then you have to
take everything off in order to poop
mm-hmm but otherwise you can just lift
up the dress and bundle it around your
front and hold it in front of here I can
picture that and and sit down and poop
like a normal mm-hmm and and you can get
help you can get help before you go into
the bathroom getting sort of all of the
undergarments in order so that no one
has to be in the bathroom with you but I
do agree that it would be best if you
didn't have to bribe so John so here's
what I would advise I would advise the
morning of your nuptials really even if
you're not wearing a wedding dress
um just just to make it a little less
stressful but just to take away one
variable
I would advise taking one capsule of
imodium a-d just one yes one should do
mm-hmm don't overdo it
no never do you may be slightly
inconveniencing your future self but
it's just I think it's great to take a
day off from a half a day off from
pooping on on your wedding day
I think that's advisable I I do this
during VidCon by the way and yeah I and
in several other circumstances when you
like you just don't want to you know you
just don't wanna so yes it is a it is a
healthy ish way to slow down your bowels
and that's that's what it's for
yeah now of course you don't want to be
taking lots and lots and lots of imodium
at lots and lots of times or you can get
something called toxic megacolon yeah
toxic megacolon is a real thing
it's a real word it is very dangerous
it's a bad it's a bad way to die and it
sounds quite fun but it's not toxic
megacolon it sounds fun but surprisingly
enough it's not ya know it sounds like a
really good hard rock band but it turns
out to be an occasionally fatal yeah
terrible terrible disease so don't don't
don't overdo it but yeah that would be
my one piece of advice we have another
question Hank this one is from Harrison
who asks Dear John and Hank do you
consider yourselves to be Renaissance
men I you know I don't want to bad-mouth
Harrison in this circumstance but he
that is one of the questions I deleted
and was like yeah we'll skip that one
cuz I don't know you know the reason I
wanted to answer it okay yeah when we
did the very controversial crash course
world history episode on the Renaissance
I googled there's this guy how J say and
he says every word in the English
language is very good and so I looked on
how J say how you pronounce Renaissance
and he says Renaissance or Renaissance
and ever since then whenever I hear the
word Venice
I insist on like saying you know a
renaissance is also an acceptable
pronunciation so just the other day
Sarah Sarah and I were doing the
crossword and she was like do you know a
Renaissance painter and I said do you
mean a Renaissance painter because I
don't really answer to Renaissance
anymore Sarah asked you if you knew any
Renaissance painters because she
couldn't come up with an e or because
she because she wondered if you did she
mostly studies contemporary art history
or mind you right right she's not an
expert in the Renaissance I will I will
say Harrison the reason I didn't want to
answer this question is cuz I didn't
think there was any way of me getting
out of it without sounding like a douche
just gone and embraced it just hugged
right out of that but in a totally
different direction from where I would
have yeah but also yeah still sounded
like a douche yeah my answer is that I
do not consider myself a Renaissance man
but I do strongly consider myself a
Renaissance man alright I do want to do
a more serious question John get get to
get to a serious one yes desperately no
I don't let's keep it with the silly
ones they're fun and easy ok let's do a
4-0 thought this one's for Patrick who
asks dear Hank and John I'm having
trouble in my personal or life and
require a good source of dubious advice
back in January my girlfriend walked out
on her job for various emotional reasons
since then she's moved into my apartment
with me and while that's fine and dandy
I work a minimum-wage job and it's hard
to make ends meet all by myself
well my girl girlfriend is looking for a
job I just don't know if she gets how
stressed I am about the situation
I've tried telling her multiple times
and she keeps telling me that she gets
it but I'm unsure about that how should
I go about telling her in a way that she
will get what I'm saying
Patrick I think she gets it I think
probably she gets it she's just also
probably very very stressed out about it
I bet she's pretty freaked out too a lot
of people know you probably like can't
it's one of those things where you can't
really discuss how freaked out you are
with each other because doing that
freaks you both further out because it
calls into question this whole sort of
like grounded central relationship in
your lives and so like that becomes more
stressful rather than less stressful
which is not particularly good advice
just an observation yes I will also say
that that having a girlfriend who has
moved in with you and and and you are
paying all of the rent is is is going to
be a stret like a source of stress it's
always going to be unless and until she
has a job to help pay the rent that or
if you're married I mean you feel like
it's it's the relationship that you want
to have the kind of structure of the
partnership that you want to have right
you have to be asking yourself like
every month you are investing like a lot
of money into this relation should know
this is a terrible way to think about it
but look bear with me there's a truly
affair of a way to think about it every
every month you're investing like $250
in this relationship I bet that's not
the central investment but it's
something to consider and n to know that
that's like that's a psychological thing
in your own mind and and and that you
say it's fine and dandy but is it though
because clearly you were you are
freaking out about it and you're
stressed about the situation so so
there's it's worth asking yourself if
you are if you were only stressed out
because you are having a hard time
paying the rent or if you're also
stressed out because you feel like you
are carrying the this burden and it is a
very difficult burden to carry but yes
my guess is that this is a very
stressful situation and there and and
there is very little as stressful as
money problems in a relationship and and
and I I think that it it's going to be
difficult to be open about it because of
how stressful it is yeah but at the same
time I do think that it like closing
down the lines of communication and not
being honest about your feelings are
probably not going to be particularly
productive this reminds me in General
Patrick then Hank and I are much better
at addressing whether or not you should
take imodium on your wedding day than we
are at giving big life advice I would
say to just try to you know try to keep
the lines of communication open and and
try to have productive conversations
instead of just like I'm really stressed
out about this yeah yeah and and also to
know that you know the emotional reasons
that your girlfriend left her job are
probably very real and the way that you
call them various emotional reasons kind
of makes me feel like you don't feel
like they are super real yeah I think
that's the other thing is that you've
got to have that you got to have that
conversation as well hey can we move on
to another very serious question okay
John this question is from Lena and she
writes whenever I'm about to sneeze and
I realize that I'm wearing my friend's
sweatshirt I feel self-conscious about
sneezing into it is it okay to do that
will I get my friends sick I mean first
off how often are you wearing your
friend sweatshirt I mean I've got a call
into question this whole like whenever
I'm wearing my friend's sweatshirt
Clause yeah I mean like is it is it
really your friend sweatshirt anymore
right I mean once you've worn your
friend sweatshirt three times and your
friend hasn't worn it once it's kind of
your sweatshirt possession is
nine-tenths of the law let me let me
submit Lena that you are in fact
sneezing into your sweatshirt that you
stole from your friend the other
question is so like are we doing like
the vampire sneeze Ryu sneeze into your
elbow pit is that the idea that was
other how else do you sneeze into us are
you like lifting it up over your mouth I
assume that she's sneezing into her
elbow pit because she's a civilized
human being who's read the CDC's most
recent guidelines on where to sneeze
okay well I'm just making sure it sounds
a little like it sounds a little like
like sneezing into your like like
lifting it up over your mouth and
sneezing like it into your body which is
terrifying that well I mean you want to
sneeze anywhere other than into your
hand which is the grossest and most
horrifying place you can possibly sneeze
yes sneeze on the thing that you then
touch everything with that I also touch
everything with
yes your sneeze on your touching
apparatus no first off Lena I want to
congratulate you on sneezing into your
elbow that is the correct way of doing
it
secondly I don't think you need to worry
since this is no longer your your friend
sweatshirt it is clearly yours thirdly
you will get your friend sick but only
if they then put their own mouth on that
same place in the sweatshirt and frankly
if that's the sort of thing that's
happening I think that this relationship
might be more serious than you know all
right Chum we got another question this
was from Akshata who asks dear Hank and
John you may have seen minutephysics
video why you should care about nukes
and I wanted to know where nuclear
winter falls on Jon's list of
eschatological anxiety thank you so much
for the question
it's definitely in my top 10 list of
ways that the human species could come
to an end but it's not near the top just
because I think that while nuclear
winter could lead to a dramatic
reduction of the the population of
humans I think that some humans would
survive it it would be like fallout well
yes but would you be one of the humans
that would survive I mean just look at
me Hank do I look like I would survive a
nuclear war oh no of course not the
apocalyptic scenario Hank I am going to
be in the first 5% of people who die
like if there's some like a 1919 style
Spanish flu I'm gonna be like patient 7
[Laughter]
the video that Henry that Henry made I
for one of the first times ever found
myself kind of disagreeing with the
premise in a minute physics video which
is that while we probably will not
intentionally destroy destroy all of
human life with a nuclear winter we
might do it by accident because we see
some sign that someone else is launching
nukes at us and then we will launch
nukes at them and then they will launch
nukes at us and then we will launch
nukes at them and and that just I don't
know I guess I have a little bit more
faith in humanity than that I I don't
know that I
have much more faith in humanity than
that I mean the issue I think the yeah I
I think the issue is that if a war that
uses nuclear weapons begins and I will
remind you that we are less than one
human lifetime into the age of nuclear
weapons that war will likely involve a
lot of radioactive fallout even if it is
relatively brief I think that it would
be pretty catastrophic I don't think
that we would be likely to reply to an
incoming barrage of 20 nuclear warheads
with an outgoing barrage of 200 and I
think that's the only way that you
really have a sudden apocalyptic event I
don't think that's like oh we could
definitely do that if we got hit with 20
nukes we could definitely shoot out 200
well we could I just don't think we
would is what I'm saying right right you
say you're saying that it's so an
interesting so I want to make sure that
all your eschatological anxiety is in
order here so the interestingly the
fallout isn't necessarily the dangerous
part it's what happens when a large city
burns mm-hmm it's it's not just the
initial explosion it's also all of the
fuel that will burn in the city and then
create and in all of the cities that
that if we are doing a nuclear attack on
cities that's the problem if we're doing
a nuclear attack on on like military
installations and on and on areas where
there might be nuclear silos like that's
a different thing if we're doing them on
city's first big problem cities are
burning second you create this massive
amount of dust that goes into the
atmosphere and and even in a relatively
small level small scale attack where
lots of cities are burning you see you
know like sort of a three year decrease
in the temperature of the earth of like
20 or 30 degrees which basically means
no more food in a lot of in a lot of
places so that's that the concern is not
the radiation it's it's the
the collapse of Agriculture okay and
that that's something that that's
something that by the way also could
happen with the supervolcano relatively
easily I was just reading an article
about how most of the mass extinctions
that we have on record were caused by
super volcanoes and in a way super
volcanoes are somewhat similar to
nuclear winter in the way that they
operate and and I just want to say that
one of one of the potential side effects
of these large large stormy events that
have lots of heat on the ground and lots
of dust being thrown up to the air is a
thing called a hyper Kane and I dislike
the word hyper Kane and I want to make a
scishow yeah I mean after hearing all of
that I think that I'm going to move
nuclear winter to the bottom of the top
five of my eschatological anxieties
instead of the bottom of the top 10
so congratulations minutephysics
you've done it also acts on - you've
done it as well I I have moved nuclear
winter up to fifth in my apocalyptic
anxieties that reminds me Hank today's
podcast is brought to you by nuclear
winter nuclear winter one of the ways
that we could ensure this podcast
doesn't reach its one-year anniversary
this podcast is also brought to you by
toxic megacolon you thought that it was
a really dope band name it turns out it
is a serious disease that you need to be
careful with so don't take too much
imodium and also today's podcast is
brought to you by the Renaissance the
Renaissance the only proper way to
pronounce the Renaissance and finally
this podcast is brought to you by Lena's
friends sweatshirt Lena's friend
sweatshirt actually leaders which I'm so
excited for Lena she just she just got a
sweatshirt like it this whole time she
thought that it was her friend's
sweatshirt but now we've given her
permission to just accept that it's hers
now all right Hank we've got another
question this one comes from Julia who
writes Dear John and Hank almost every
time I leave the house with my mother
she makes a comment about the sky like
it didn't used to be like this everyone
needs to wake up the man is trying to
control us or the weather she's kind of
obsessed with the man she is in general
as smart human but every time she opens
up
mouths and uses the word geoengineering
or chemtrails or cloud seeding I want to
roll my eyes so hard when I google
geothermal engineering and chemtrails I
can't find any legit scientific evidence
or Studies on it so I thought hey I bet
John could pretend to know the answer
and then Hank could step in and astound
us with the sciency knowledge on this
subject so here I am asking if there is
any relevance at all to my mother's
claims should I be joining my mom and
her annoyed rants about the man or
should I just let her spew off her
nonsense while I ignore from the
passenger side I'm very sorry this
question doesn't involve death I mean
unless geoengineering is real and the
man is trying to kill us all with this
chemtrail experiments
sincerely longtime fan and creator and
gifter of the 2011 Swindon Town swirly
poopers FA Cup Champions Trophy plate by
the way Julia thank you very much for
that it remains one of my all-time
favorite gifts I'm not even gonna
pretend to know the answer to this
because I don't even know what
chemtrails in geothermal engineering are
well several times you said geothermal
Internet engineering when you meant
geoengineering geothermal engineering is
probably the process of building a power
plant based on geothermal energy which
is not what we're talking about geo
engine what geoengineering would be the
process of attempting to engineer the
processes of the planet to control them
to control the weather you know it's
something that people talk about when
you know we're like okay so the globe is
warming
how do we like can we dial that back
because even if we go like two degrees
up in the short-term like in a hundred
years that's gonna be bad but in a
thousand years it's gonna be terrible so
how do we how do we could like we have
unintentionally controlled the climate
how do we intentionally control it to
maybe make it stable again and that's a
legitimate area of current sort of
scientific thought and there are even
some times when we are thinking about
actually doing things that would affect
the climate so like whether that's cloud
seeding or to reflect sunlight back into
the sky or into space or various other
other projects that have been tried and
very sort of like small-scale
experiments to see if they actually have
an effect even locally or even I think
that Russia thought about creating a
mirror that would shine light down on
Siberia a mirror in space that would
shine light down on Siberia and like
increase the amount of radiation that
that area of the world is getting which
would be you know also a way of at least
local local geoengineering but
chemtrails are if you would have never
heard of a chem trail good but they are
the the the idea that those the
contrails that you see in the sky when a
plane is going overhead the sort of that
basically that the water vapor being
released from the plane and the heat
being released from the plane is
creating a cloud in the sky and the idea
of a chem trail is that that's not a
cloud it is in fact some kind of
chemical that people are using the
government is using to control us or to
or to try and change the weather or to
do something generally something
insidious that's not true at all
and a lot of people have gotten really
connected with this idea there's a lot
of really you know exciting conspiracy
theories they are conspiracy theories
it's not real and those are just clouds
that planes make the clouds that planes
make could have an effect on the climate
just by being clouds but they are made
of water vapour not of anything
dangerous and that's that's it it's so
that's the situation
geoengineering is an active area of
low-level scientific research chemtrails
do not exist they are actually just
clouds and but dealing with someone who
believes conspiracy theories who is
important in your life is always hard
and I don't have a ton of advice for
that except to just keep loving them
anyway
yeah I'm inclined to agree with you Hank
but mostly I'm just happy that you just
talked for so long because it means that
you might talk more than me in this
podcast I have another question for you
Hank this is also a kind of Hank
oriented question it comes from Garda or
Gerta from Sweden could also be
pronounced Renaissance I'm not positive
she writes dear John and Hank if I as a
human female were pregnant with kittens
would I be pregnant for nine months like
a human or nine weeks like a cat PS this
is rather urgent so I don't I don't know
why it's urgent
IV there's a couple there's a couple
possibilities one of which is truly
alarming but well yes what one of the
one of the potential reasons yes for
Gerta the good news is that it can't be
that urgent unless you are nine weeks
pregnant pregnant with kittens yeah not
least because you're about to have some
kittens if you're only three weeks
pregnant with kittens and I'm not super
concerned but if you're nine weeks
pregnant with kittens you do need to go
see a doctor now the situation here is
that the pregnancy is determined both by
the physiology of the mother and by the
child but you do not want to have any
child that is in the womb for longer
than it was designed to be in the womb
for so the the cats are gonna have to
come out even if your body isn't ready
for them to come out which is fine
because we have all kinds of medical
procedures that are you know not the
best thing to have to go through in the
world but we have have them and you can
get a c-section and have the cat's
removed and they will be healthy will
they will they be healthy yes I mean yes
they will deed you will need to find a
nursemaid a wet nurse cat mother to take
care of them or or you know that would
be the ideal situation or you could you
know bottle feed them with with cat
formula but I think it's gonna be fine I
do have some questions though I have a
couple of big concerns Hank at number
one if I implanted kitten embryos into a
human womb would I actually get cats ah
you would not know you would oh okay
good I mean I was freaking out for a
second there this just we are not we are
not similar enough for that to happen
unless
Gurdurr from sweden has some really
interesting physiology you know I think
I have grown uncomfortable with this
question and feel that we should move on
so yeah we're we're I I'm calling it
okay we've got another question this
one's from Lorelai John who asks dear
Hank and John it's a slightly more
serious question so get ready recently
my fiancee discovered he has a daughter
that he was previously unaware of not
only did he wait two months to tell me
about said daughter but now he wants to
postpone our wedding that I did all the
planning for I'm very conflicted I'm
angry at him for not confiding in me but
also I want to give him the time and
space he needs my fiance and I have been
dancing around each other for literally
like ten years and I've been so excited
to actually finally get married to him
now I feel like everything is falling
apart what should I do any any dubious
advice is this question from a character
in the television program the Gilmore
Girls sang it I really was hoping that
you would answer it what a great
question first off thanks to the Gilmore
Girls for writing and always a pleasure
you know it's funny because when you
write the when you write the plot
summary of the Gilmore Girls like that
my general like my advice would have
been I don't know about you Hank but my
advice would have been like I I feel
like you should probably take 10 to 12
steps back well I mean he was unaware of
it so if it had been something like if
it'd have been a secret for your entire
relationship then I would say yes
definitely take 10 to 12 steps back but
but if he's freaking out and he takes
two months to tell you about it after he
finds out I think that that's not cool
but it's like there is a way of
understanding that like in a
relationship the main thing the main I
guess the main thing for me is that it
reminds me that real real life both
fictional real life and non fictional
real life are so complicated in
particular that really advice is
profound
the dubious like even yes yes even
advice that that advertises itself as
dubious like ours is even more dubious
than it seems at first glance because
everyone's life is so specific and so
particular and and we don't know the
whole truth of your story and in fact
like neither do you right so yeah it
just reminds me that the whole concept
of an advice show is ludicrous right
well and also like it reminds me that I
have to say to Goethe you know live your
life the way you want to live it and and
if you want to help we're not going back
to the kittens I refuse to answer one
more question before we get to the
all-important news from Mars and AFC
Wimbledon this question Hank comes from
Wyman Dear John Hank I am Ty and here we
have more than 20 types of bananas
bananas are so easy to find here we grow
both intentionally and unintentionally
bananas everywhere even in our own
backyard stop talking to me about heaven
Wyman the Cavendish banana is not that
popular here my question is why is the
rest of the world only eating Cavendish
bananas when there are several other
alternatives which are tastier on
another note I've seen bananas that are
rectangular triangular Pentagon tent
agonal pentagonal and even ones that
seem circular we may have got this part
out but John just said pentagonal there
he almost said pentagonal and I just I
wish that you would kept like I thought
myself before I said pentagonal
good-old that's you know egg things come
in multiple shapes you know they can be
diagonal they can be tri agonal they can
be quadriga no or they can be pentagonal
I know the answer to this question if
you want to know I bet the answer is
that Cavendish bananas are Hardy er and
even though they don't taste very good
they're easy to ship basically yeah not
only are they easy to ship and Hardy
they are also easy to ripe it on command
so a Cavendish banana you unripe for a
very long time and then expose them to a
chemical that tells them to ripen and
then put them on the shelves at the
supermarket and
and that allows for bananas to come from
a very long way away and still be always
and and always not spoil before they get
to the store which is quite cool
Cavendish thank you that is good um and
and also like I think that that the
Cavendish banana is quite good there is
something very nice about the simplicity
of its flavor and that makes it I think
appealing very broadly whereas other
bananas have stronger flavors that are
you know might be more exciting and but
like maybe not best for breakfast every
single morning of your life but I could
be wrong
I haven't had all of these wonderful
heavenly bananas that Wyman seems to be
constantly exposed to and and is making
me very jealous Hank and I are so old
and moderate that we even like our
bananas to be pretty standard its how
like how old and like risk-averse are
you well I don't want a delicious banana
in the morning that's how risk-averse I
am yeah I just sort of want I want a you
know normal plain what you might call a
vanilla banana actually vanilla banana
sounds quite good yeah do you have
anything do you have anything that's
less tasty that's what I always say when
I call down to room service I've just
I'm wondering if you could make these
eggs a bit bland err ah can I tell you a
start about room service job yes but
then we have to get to the week's news
from Mars and AFC Wimbledon not least
because the Champions League is about to
start one time I was in a foreign
country and I asked for a sprite through
room service because I was getting food
and they said lemonade and I said no
sprite and they said ok and then they
brought and then what I got was a wine
spritzer and I was like well this is not
definitely not sprite but what I found
out was that in that country sprite and
and other drinks like it fizzy
lemon-lime drinks are called lemonade
and now I know that whereas in America
eliminate always does not have bubbles
that is correct
lemonade always does not have bubbles
Hank is there ad did anything
interesting happen on the cold dead Rock
known as Mars this week lots of
interesting things happened
it's always so hard to pick just one by
the way but if you you're aware that
Mars has weather correct John yes so
Mars has dust storms it has it has
you know poles and like in it's warmer
in the middle and colder at the tops and
and all kinds of cool weather things
happen on Mars but they are somewhat
more rare than the weather things that
happen here on earth one of the things
that happens our dust devils and we can
see the tracks of these dust devils and
the pictures that we take they're very
difficult to see though that the devils
themselves when you're looking from the
top because they're vertical structures
but opportunity the rover was just
taking a picture and happened to catch a
dust devil as it passed behind it and so
you can go and see NASA's photo of this
cute little dust devil and and
opportunity's rover tracks reaching off
into the distance and I just think that
it's so cool to see things happening on
the surface of Mars as they happen and
it's so nice to have several concurrent
missions happening at the same time on
Mars and I'm excited for more and more
of them to be they're sending us these
beautiful photos okay we'll try to put
that up on the patreon you can go to
patreon.com/scishow
but you can also just see stuff at the
patreon even if you don't contribute and
we won't be mad we understand but your
support the the people who do support us
allows us to help defray the costs of
Nick and Claudia who work on the on the
podcast so thank you as for the news
from AFC Wimbledon Hank mmm-hmm so you
will recall that last week the news was
that we were making an AFC Wimbledon
movie which is very exciting yes that's
very exciting
however you will also recall that I kind
of buried the fact that AFC Wimbledon
season more or less ended with a loss to
Hartlepool leaving them in 10th place in
League Two
in a game that that was widely believed
they had to win and the reason they had
to win that game was because they were
almost certainly going to lose away at
Wykeham the next week or Wickham or
possibly why come B nobody knows for
sure how to pronounce it as it is a
fictional town made up by people who
live in England presumably as a joke
their their their mascot seems to be a
puffin anyway they are doing quite well
in League Two and so the thought was
that we were going to lose that game
away but instead AFC Wimbledon won that
game and while they are still in 10th
place they have the proverbial game in
hand they have played one fewer game
than the four teams above them which
means that if they were to win that
hypothetical game if like if every team
won every game between now and the end
of the season which is now just six
games away from most teams seven games
away for AFC Wimbledon then then
Wimbledon would end up seventh in the
table and would indeed go to the
playoffs so the hope is once again alive
due to two goals from the montserrat Ian
Messi that man wild Taylor the great
Lyle Taylor the Messi for Montserrat the
Christiano Ronaldo of Caribbean island
oohs I'm sure I'm still working on on a
new nicknames for him I'm not quite all
the way there but he scored two goals
and Wimbledon seem to be getting healthy
at the right time center back will
Nightingale one of the best surnames and
all the football is coming back to from
injury there's a bunch of good things
happening so suddenly hope that thing
with feathers that refuses to go away is
back in Wimbledon's lives and with seven
games to go it's pretty exciting
you know what also is the thing with
feathers John what the mascot of the
Wycombe Wanderers is to be either a
goose or a duck but definitely not not a
puffins also possibly a swan I'm not
sure it's some kind of water bird yeah
it's it's
you could tell it's a water bird because
I think it is efficient its mouth nope
that's a crowd holding a crown in its
mouth the best the best thing is that it
appears to be pooping a necklace I'm
sure I'm sure why come is a lovely place
but you're the mascot of your football
team is is a waterfowl pooping a
necklace the world things have happened
in observing right for our last question
I'm gonna give you half a question do
you ready for half a question okay all
right this is from Matilda who asks dear
Hank and John today is the first day
when I have caught up with the entire
podcast Thank You Matilda meaning that I
will start listening to my brother my
brother in me instead of dear Hank and
John while dissecting beetle genitalia
now I love the beginning of this
question so much that I had to read it
the rest of the question is an appeal to
us to appreciate pennies more and I have
no interest in reading that sorry
Matilda there are some things we will
never change our mind on but thank you
for writing in oh man lovely thoughts
and you know I would love to know
whether Matilda died sex Beatle
genitalia for fun or for work or you
know maybe it's one of those things
where your passion and your career
happened to line up perfectly but I will
refuse I will continue to refuse to to
say anything positive about the penny
which should never be used ever again as
it does not in any way facilitate the
exchange of goods and services which is
the purpose of currency currency has no
secondary purpose it is supposed to make
it easier and for us to behave in
economically rational ways the penny is
a wonderful example of the failure of
markets to act in rational ways and I
will not hear any arguments to the
counter it's one of the very few things
I feel so strongly about that I cannot
even bring myself to read penny
apologists thank what did we learn today
oh gosh
so many things John I know is really it
was a day of learning it's so hard to
distill it into four things
John we learned that sometimes a
football team can win even when the
people think they're gonna lose to a
goose with a necklace hanging out of its
butt we learned it that if you're
pregnant with kittens you you you
shouldn't be pregnant for too long so I
guess that's good news we learned that
there are healthy ish ways to not poop
for a whole day and also that nuclear
winter is scary at least to John and of
course we learned that Renaissance can
also be pronounced Renaissance or must
also be pronounced Renaissance
apparently thanks for listening to our
podcast and for sending in all of your
questions you can send in questions to
us at Hank and John at gmail.com you can
also use the hashtag dear Hank and John
on Twitter where I'm John Green Hank is
Hank green you can also follow us on
snapchat I've gotten a little bit into
snapchat recently Hank is Hank gr II I
am John Green snaps or John Green snaps
really depending on your worldview our
podcast is produced and edited by
nicholas jenkins our intern is claudia
morales rosianna halse rojas helps out
with the questions our theme music is by
gunnarolla thank you again for listening
and as we say in our hometown don't
forget to be awesome
you
[Music]